Hôm nay, hay 18, 2 cạnh xa lần đôn đã bắt giữ cụ đại xuyện tại Mỹ ông Peter Madison với cáu bốc
Nhiên Vee Pham trên những công buồn trong bối cảnh bế bối liên quan đến nhà tại chính Jeffree F.T.
Tế tục gửi chân độc chính trường anh sau khi các emel zor bộ từ pham Mỹ công bố hội quay thả một cho thấy
một quanh hệ dự ông Madison và F.T. gần buồn hơn sau vinh những gì ông thử nhận.
Ông Madison chức lòng gói rất hội hạnh về việc quen biết F.T.
Vyện bắt giữ công đồng viện ở với kyl lận có tội.
Vụ việc làm gia tăng thêm sự áp đối với thu tưởng kia stammer người tương bộ nhiệm ông Madison làm đại sự tại Mỹ năm 2020.
Chức đó, 2 tập giới thân cận của ông stammer trong phụ tưởng cũng đã phải tư trước vì liên quan tới công tác bộ nhiệm ông Madison.
Ngoài ra khôi anh đã yêu cầu công bố tại liệu liên quanên quanên quanên hảo chá chức tình bộ nhiệm.
Bế bộ F.T. gói chí tác động tới chính phủ mà còn lan xa ngạng hòn ra anh.
Tổn chốc cố hảo từ Andrew, em trải cố cường chào sức tâm cũng đã bị bắt tạm dưới.
Để phục cộng điều tra dân lên quan tới các cấp bộ có liên hệ và S.T.